ils sont attendus par les enfants et
surtout les parents les cahiers de
vacances connaissent chaque été un grand
succès parmi toutes ces références l'une
d'elles a été conçu à chatou dans les
yvelines
alors qu'elle est professeur des écoles
virginie becker ne trouve pas son
bonheur dans les cahiers existants pour
ses enfants elle décide de se lancer
dans l'aventuré jules et léonie il ya
cinq ans j'ai eu cette idée de créer des
cahiers de vacances qu'ils fassent
grandir l'enfant dans toutes ses
dimensions qui est pas que la partie
scolaire mais qui a aussi des aspects
qui vraiment dû fasse prendre confiance
en lui
les deux personnages voyage au coeur de
l'histoire tout en faisant réviser les
notions de l'année écoulée un frère et
une soeur nés sous le crayon de laëtitia
ami d'enfance de la fondatrice des
cahiers nous sommes tombés tout de suite
d'accord sur une ambiance graphique et
coloré
on voulait des cahiers qui soit à la
fois ludique et sérieux mais que le côté
ludique apporte la dimension d'apprendre
en s'amusant aux enfants et jules leoni
ont été rejoints par une petite mascotte
qui s'appelle pouic pouic le canard pour
apporter cette petite touche d'humour
décalé chaque cahier nécessite un an
d'écriture commercialisé pour la
première fois en 2019 dans les
librairies et de grandes enseignes
culturelles
il existe pour l'instant trois niveaux
l'année dernière on en a imprimé 3000
donc les trois confondues
on a quasiment tout vendu donc ça
c'était on était contente avec laeticia
parce qu'on est un peu le flou
artistique on savait pas trop et donc
cette année on en a un prix mais trois
fois plus deux autres niveaux devrait
être disponible l'année prochaine
en plus des exercices de maths et de
français les cahiers propose des petites
pépites moment à partager en famille ou
encore des leçons de bonne heure